geico ordered to pay missouri woman 5.2
million after she contracted std in car
geico must pay 5.2 million to a woman
who got hpv from sex in men's insured
car court rules well i'm sorry to tell
you that the headlines are wrong
but the truth is even more interesting
because it involves
nuances and esoteric details of
insurance law now you may have heard
that geico was on the hook for 5 million
because a woman contracted hpv after she
had sex with a man in his 2014 hyundai
genesis that was insured by geico and it
is true that a thing happened that a
lawsuit was filed between the former
couple the man knew he apparently had
throat cancer that was caused by hpv but
did not tell the woman that he had it
she took him to an arbitration and was
awarded more than 5 million dollars as
lawyer ellie mistahl put it that was
probably an expensive 15 minutes for
geico
[Music]
now it occurs to me that i probably
should have put a warning on this
episode if there are any kids watching
sex is when two people love each other
and then wrestle in the back of a car in
this case a 2014 hyundai genesis and
when those two people no longer love
each other they will sue each other for
what happened in that car now
how does that implicate geico you might
ask well the man's car was insured by
geico the encounter happened in 2017 and
one filed an insurance claim which geico
denied geico told the woman its auto
insurance coverage didn't apply because
the damages claimed did not arise out of
the normal use of the vehicle which i
think we can all agree probably makes
sense and now to understand this whole
case we have to take our first diversion
into the nuances of insurance law
because generally speaking when you get
an insurance policy it provides
insurance over you know let's say an
accident happening an occurrence of some
kind but in addition you'll often get
what's called a duty to defend in other
words if you are sued over something
that might be covered by the policy then
the insurance company has to provide
lawyers
or at least the funds for lawyers to
defend that case
[Music]
now when an insurance company refuses to
defend its policy holder it's considered
basically the same as denying coverage
outright saying that the policy doesn't
cover the accident that happened so an
insurance company that wrongfully
refuses to defend its insured can be
liable for the cost of the defense and
any damages that arise from the breach
of their duty to defend now how do you
know if a policy is going to apply to an
accident or whether the insurance
company has a duty to defend you well
you look to the four corners of the
complaint in the lawsuit and you compare
that to the policy itself this is called
the four corners rule or sometimes the
eight quarters you're comparing what's
contained inside the lawsuit complaint
to what's contained inside the policy
and if it's possible if it's
a remote possibility that this claim
could be covered by the insurance policy
then the insurance company has to
provide you with a defense now if the
allegations are untrue then the
insurance company won't have to pay a
judgment because well they'll win but
you can't know that until the trial is
over which is why the insured needs
someone to pay for their defense and
that's why there's often a duty to
defend under certain policies and that's
why sometimes the defense costs are the
whole ballgame if the insurance company
denies the defense then the insured
might be in a world of trouble they have
to defend against a lawsuit all on their
own and
lawyers are expensive now an old partner
of mine used to say that the only thing
an insurance policy gets you is the
right to sue an insurance company in
other words if they deny your defense or
deny coverage then you might have to sue
the insurance company if you lose the
initial case going forward uh but that's
why some plaintiffs attorneys will
actually specifically try to cast their
allegations in a way that will invoke
insurance coverage so that they make
sure the insurance company is part of
the litigation they'll either add
another claim or they will craft the
story of what happened in a way that
might fall under coverage of the
insurance company because the insurance
companies tend to be the ones that have
the big pockets so now we come back to
this particular case in february of 2021
the woman sent geico a copy of a lawsuit
that she was about to file against the
insured the guy that she had sex with in
the car she offered to settle the claim
for one million dollars geico ignored
the notice basically geico decided that
the claim wasn't covered and refused to
defend basically geico said having sex
in a car that we insure is not covered
under the policy so we're not going to
provide coverage and we're not going to
provide a defense to the guy whose car
it was and for the record uh these
people
only use their initials in the lawsuit
which was probably an incredibly smart
decision so that they don't go down in
history uh for something that may or may
not have happened in this particular
suit and for the record m.o is the
injured party she's the one that
contracted hpv
mb is the man with the car who gave her
hpv so now we're in 2021 mb is going to
defend this lawsuit on his own dime
because geico has refused to provide a
defense so geico basically takes itself
out of the picture at which point the
the insured mb the guy with the car and
the sti enter into an arbitration
agreement with mo in march of 2021 and
they agree to settle their dispute
through arbitration now missouri's
insurance laws have some procedural
quirks and the relevant statute is
section 537.065
that statute allows a claimant like mo
to enter into a contract with the torq
feaser here mb the guy with the hpv to
settle their dispute in private
arbitration which would be much much
cheaper and much much quicker than going
to trial in state court now you're
allowed to enter into one of these
agreements when the insurance company
has refused to defend the insured or
agrees to a defense on under a
reservation of rights which i won't go
into now the parties enter arbitration
with an agreement that the maximum
payout that the arbitrator can give is
whatever the insurance policy limits are
and generally that the the plaintiff
won't go after the defendant the
tortfeasor
and will just take the judgment and use
it against the insurance company which
as discussed depends on whether the
claim is covered or not effectively the
plaintiff is gambling that the claim is
or should have been covered and if they
win in arbitration they're going to take
that award and say you insurance company
you should have covered your uh insured
and therefore you can just pay me
everything that was owed because we made
this side agreement so in other words
once you get an award in arbitration
either the insured sues the insurance
company and turns that money over to the
claimant or the claimant standing in the
shoes of the insured sues the insurance
company saying that they wrongfully
denied coverage or defense costs that's
called subrogation now obviously
insurance companies hated all of this
and that's why this section has been
amended twice once in 2017 and once in
2021 and this is effectively exactly
what happened here they went to
arbitration without geico because geico
said they didn't want to participate
they didn't think it was covered and the
claimant got an award of 5.2 million
dollars
and the arbitrator found and yes this is
the actual language that the arbitrator
had to find because uh law is uh is
interesting the arbitrator found quote
there was sexual activity in insurance
automobile in november december of 2017
which occurred in jackson county
missouri two the sexual activity in
insurance vehicle directly caused or
directly contributed to
mo to be infected with hpv three insured
knew or had been told his throat cancer
was diagnosed as hpv positive four
insured should have disclosed his
diagnosis to mo prior to their sexual
activity that occurred and he did not
and five ensured was negligent and is
liable for causing ammo to contract hpv
the arbitrator found that the amount
that would fairly and justly compensate
plaintiff mo for all for damages and
injuries is 5.2 million dollars and
entered an award in that amount in favor
of plaintiff mo and against the
defendant the insured so in the end the
arbitrator awarded her 5.2 million
dollars in damages and so the headlines
were sort of right that mo did get a
judgment for 5.2 million dollars against
the guy that screwed her pun absolutely
intended
but here it just wasn't against geico
yet geico asserted that the plaintiff
and defendant had conspired to jack up
the damages award in the arbitration
mo's council says that this wasn't the
situation in their case that the
liability and damages were determined on
the merits and the arbitration
proceeding was not based on any
admissions and that it was fairly
contested there were
arguments and witnesses going both ways
but after this arbitration award the
woman informed uh the insured that she
would file an action in state court to
confirm the damages award which is what
you do when you get an arbitration award
you then basically confirm it in state
court now at this point geico tried to
intervene they wanted a new trial
because they didn't think the
arbitration was fair that motion was
denied but at the same time in april
2021 geico filed a separate suit in
federal court in the district of kansas
seeking a determination that it has no
duty to defend or indemnify mb the guy
with hpv
so geico chose to fight its case on two
friends one in the state court and one
in federal court and it's really the
federal court case that's going to
determine on the merits whether geico
actually has to provide a defense or
provide indemnity based on the contract
language we'll come back to that in a
second now in state court geico argued
that the judgment in the arbitration
violated the company's due process
rights and the arbitration agreement was
unenforceable geico said it never had an
opportunity to participate in discovery
or to provide a meaningful defense and
by the time that they were aware of the
judgment they argued it was too late and
you can see some merit to this they
didn't get a chance to contest the facts
in this more or less secret arbitration
where the claimant and the insured might
have colluded to drive up the award and
at the very least the insured didn't
care because by virtue of the agreement
that he made he wasn't on the hook for
the damages so he might not have
colluded but he also didn't care if
there was this giant judgment because
the plaintiff mo was just going to turn
around and sue geico over it now on the
other hand this arbitration and this
award it's not against geico it's an
award against mb the hpv guy
if geico was right the policy doesn't
cover it then they don't have to pay and
we'll talk about that in a second
whether the policy covers it and if
geico wanted to participate in this from
the very beginning and they were worried
that they would have to
pay indemnity to mb or cover his defense
costs then they could have provided him
a defense from the very beginning that's
the point of the duty to defend and
that's why state laws are often crafted
in a way to incentivize insurance
companies to provide a defense because
you can't go back in time and provide a
defense after the fact so if you the
insurance company are worried that you
might have to cover the damages award
well then provide a defense to the guy
that you provided insurance and
participate throughout the entire thing
as the missouri court found quote
geico's claim of constitutional
deprivations presumes geico was denied
the opportunity to defend its interests
relating to mo's claims against insured
including the ability to challenge
liability and damages but geico did have
the opportunity to participate and
defend its interests including the
ability to challenge liability and
damages by entering a defense of the
insured geico did not take advantage of
this opportunity and instead denied
coverage and refused to defend insured
moreover geico initiated a declaratory
judgment action in federal court seeking
a determination as to its obligations
under the insurance policy and that
federal action provides yet another
forum in which geico may defend its
interests and right the federal court
action geico is currently suing in
federal court for an order that says the
policy doesn't cover the hpv
transmission at all and if they win they
won't have to pay anything no part of
the 5.2 million because that judgment is
only against mb so the headlines were
wrong there has been no determination
that geico was responsible for this 5.2
million dollar award
for now there's also no determination
that geico wrongfully denied a defense
to mb
but they might now usually if someone
files an insurance claim because they
were injured in a car it's because of an
accident that's one of the reasons that
this seems like an unfair ruling it puts
insurance companies in a weird position
of defending any and all claims no
matter how bonkers they might seem but
it's really a question of whether the
insurance policy actually applies to
this scenario geico asserted that
there's no way as policy can be
interpreted to include this kind of
negligence the woman sued over
contracting an sti in a car but to
determine that we have to look at the
policy language generally since
insurance companies write these policies
the language is construed against them
let me know if you've ever had a chance
to write a custom insurance endorsement
generally the insurance company gives
you what they give you which is why
policies are often hundreds of pages
long they're trying to prevent any and
all weird situation so in this
particular case
what does the policy say well i had to
do some digging but i found the relevant
language in geico's appellate brief
according to geico the policy covers
bodily injuries arising out of the
ownership operation maintenance or use
of a motor vehicle now you might notice
that language is very broad
does this type of injury arise out of
the ownership of a car well
it seems like a lot of stuff arises out
of the ownership does it qualify as use
of the motor vehicle maybe is this a
bodily injury maybe is it the type of
bodily injury that's intended to be
covered by uh an insurance policy who
knows but for the most part you're just
looking at the text and the meaning of
the words that are in the policy itself
construed
against the insurance company or in the
light that is uh more favorable to the
insured so it's possible that geico
might have to cover this because if it's
even possible that this language covers
this situation then geico was wrong to
deny a defense to mb the insured and
they're going to be on the hook for not
only the attorney's fees but also the
award of damages itself but we'll know
soon geico filed a lawsuit in federal
court seeking a declaratory judgment
that it is not responsible for this
situation and that is scheduled for
trial in october but even if geico loses
don't consider this a license to engage
in unsafe sex because you can bet that
geico has already changed the policy
language in all of its car policies to
make sure
that uh no future policies cover this
situation in the future but either way
it seems this is the new mcdonald's hot
coffee case people completely
misunderstood what was happening in this
particular case but it is another
example of using your car for weird
things but really people instead of
using your car since we're all working
from home you should upgrade your
decoration i recently upgraded my office
with the help of today's sponsor display
this plate sells high quality metal art
prints that couldn't be easier to
install i've been using display
literally for years even before they
were a sponsor here let me show you
here's the one i've had for years
easy to switch out
boom
adjust it
looks good this plate is great because
you never have to deal with a cheap
looking plastic frame or trying to make
sure it's perfectly straight because you
can hang them up using magnets
installation is a breeze and you can
easily swap them out with whatever you
want there are no nails and no holes you
can adjust it or replace it however you
want display it has millions of designs
ranging from movies vintage posters maps
art music nature and the list goes on
and on i actually chose a bunch of
inside legal jokes
here's a patent application for a gavel
but whether you are a law nerd like me
you will find something that you love
that you want to display every single
day and this month display is offering a
summer sale where if you purchase using
the link below you'll get 25 off one or
two displays and a whopping 29 off three
or more and it's automatically applied
to your cart at checkout so click on the
link in the description or the link
that's on screen right now to
automatically get a huge discount on
whatever disk plate that you want and
revamp your home or office plus click on
that link really helps out this channel
and while you're at it click on this
playlist over here with all my other
legal videos so click on this link or
i'll see you in court